[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
dans le dernier set 8 loisirs de 2016
vos idées sorties dans le département on
commence ensuite avec le sommaire de ce
numéro
j moins avant noël et l'avalanche de
cadeaux le père noël a beaucoup de
travail pour satisfaire tous les enfants
mais il nous a réservé une petite
surprise les vacances continuent et les
spectacles de l'académie équestre aussi
c'est l'occasion de découvrir la voie de
l'écuyer et de visiter les écuries avant
la fermeture jusqu'en février enfin qui
dit nouvelle année dit veut mélanie
poker nous apprendra à sauter le
meilleur pour 2017
en réalisant ses propres cartes de voeux
et je vous le disais en titre le père
noël ne nous a réservé une surprise il a
accepté de faire un passage sur notre
plateau il nous accompagnera tout le
long de l'émission bonjour père noël
bonjour mais peut-être que oui bordeaux
le mot merci beaucoup d'être venu sur
notre plateau d'autant plus que vous
avez énormément de travail j - en avant
le réveillon avec volutes ans est en
pleine préparation des cadeaux les
emballer et surtout les livrer en temps
et en heure pour tous les enfants
est ce que tout se passe comme vous
souhaiter pour l'instant il cotait et
tout va bien on travaille beaucoup les
usines tournent à fond en laponie les
petits lutins font leur maximum
les p'tits déj de la mère noël aussi
plus
les reine des reines est prête elle est
en pleine forme et on n'attend plus que
le départ on est en train de charger le
traîneau magique et voilà eh ben ce sont
des supers nouvelles merci beaucoup père
noël on va poursuivre d'entretien juste
après mais je voudrais tout d'abord
faire un bond vers la rentrée avec un
rendez vous à ne pas manquer c'est le 14
janvier à versailles la troupe pour
chantiers présentera sa nouvelle pièce
créée au mois molière en juin dernier
faut pas pousser mémé une comédie écrite
et mise en scène par pierre ory guette
elle raconte le deuil d'un avocat suite
au décès de sa mère un événement qui va
faire ressurgir de boer secrets de
famille on regarde en extrait du teaser
mais mais c'est ma mère elisabeth chopin
elle vient nourrir la pièce ça parle de
quoi
deux mois en fait et la façon dont je
vais être amené à gérer les formalités
suivant le décès de ma mère mais il n'y
a pas ça frédéric et je laisse parler
s'il te plaît mais cammalleri et
jusqu'au 31 décembre l'espace richaud de
versailles vous propose un tour du monde
des jouets l'exposition toy story de
l'artiste italien gabriela galimberti
présente 24 photographies de jeunes
enfants posant avec leurs jouets favoris
un espace jeux est également mis à
disposition des visiteurs ateliers jeux
en bois billard hollandais ballet on
écoute la réaction il avait de la can a
[Musique]
tiré des balles et celui-là on donne
comment facile ça dépend des détours
eiffage et c'est une exposition très
intéressante
on voit bien les différences entre des
enfants quitte à fabriquer leurs fouets
et ceux qui ont tout à profusion
en raison des récents
je parlais à l'instant d'un tour du
monde des jouets vous père noël ou fait
ça tous les ans alors nom au bateau
comme le vendée globe qui se déroule
actuellement
mais en traîneau alors on imagine que
vooren sont prêts à partir y semant les
starting blocks pourquoi le traîneau
qu'est-ce que ça qu'est-ce que ça permet
et ben écoutez moi je suis un pays où on
utilise le traîneau depuis des années
des années
alors voilà c'est devenu mon véhicule à
moi et puis j'ai mon bonnet qui me
permet de faire de la magie est alors
quand j'ai besoin de mon traîneau
magique pour traverser le monde entier
hop
j'active mon bonnet avec les rennes
c'est pareil alors la hausse en vol et
au traverse le monde entier alors c'est
vrai au fait le nord au sud de l'est à
l'ouest dans tous les coins du monde en
24 heures
ça marche du tonnerre aucun enfant n'est
laissé de côté et d'ailleurs vous
échangez aussi avec eux pour connaître
leurs envies de cadeaux il ya eu des
boîtes aux lettres qui ont été mises en
place notamment à plaisir pour pouvoir
vous envoyer des lettres ce type de
dispositif est ce que ça vous est de
vraiment c'est vraiment utile il faut
continuer oui il faut continuer oui ça
nous aide beaucoup parce que ça nous
permet de gagner du temps vous comprenez
elle sinon après il faut qu'on fasse
toutes les enquêtes nous même les petits
lutins sont débordés les petits elfes
aussi alors les courriers ça nous fait
gagner du temps et puis ce qui est très
très mignon c'est tous les mots gentils
ils vous comprenez moi ça me fais un
plaisir fou à chaque fois d'ouvrir une
lettre est de voir les mots gentils des
petits enfants alors comment est-ce
qu'on s'a qu'ils ont quand ce que vous
savez qu'ils ont été sages serait en a
qui sont pas très sage 1 comment ça se
passe enfin j'aimerai toujours la
question d'être sage ou passage c'est
toujours la question qu'on pose au père
noël mais bon le père noël il est gentil
alors moi je sais quand je touche le
courrier d'un enfant si je touche mon
bonnet en même temps je sais tout de
suite s'il a été très sage ou parles tu
peux moi mais bon il aura toujours un
cadeau quand même c'est noël un petit
peu moins 10 points de cadeaux s'il a
moins été sage en voilà
elle anime noël vous le rapportez
justement des cadeaux mais eux aussi
vous laisse parfois des petits présents
c'est vrai c'est vrai parfois on trouve
un petit verre de lait chaud une
clémentine orange biscuits et chocolats
des confiseries enfin des petites choses
pour nous donner un peu d'énergie alors
on partage avec les petits lutins et les
rênes et comme ça ça nous donne de la
force pour aller jusqu'au bout de la
nuit et faire toute la distribution et
sa n'alourdit pas à votre très doucement
tous ces cadeaux et ramenez vous aussi
non parce que vous savez en fait nous on
a déchargé les cadeaux et en charge les
confiseries alors père noël maintenant
on a plus parlé de rennes mais d'un
autre animal à quatre pattes tout aussi
majestueux c'est le cheval les vacances
de noël c'est l'occasion d'en profiter
pour visiter l'académie équestre de
versailles
deux représentations du spectacle la
voie de l'écuyer sont encore programmés
avant la fermeture de l'établissement
aperçue dans ce reportage
c'est un spectacle entre expression
artistique et technique de dressage
chorégraphié par bartabas et l'académie
équestre de versailles la voie de
l'écuyer livre un opus 2016 toujours
aussi varié c'est un spectacle de
répertoire son appel spécial de
répertoire ses notes spectacle est le
même depuis quasiment l'ouverture de
l'académie donc le même pas tout à fait
c'est un spectacle qui évolue avec le
temps avec les chevaux les cavaliers les
disciplines artistiques divers et variés
que nous pratiquons cette année
l'académie a accueilli de nouveaux
chevaux dont un spécialisé dans les
cabrioles grâce à leur apprentissage
auprès de professeurs les 10es cuillé
maîtrise aussi bien d'équitation que les
scream note danse ou de chant
[Musique]
le cheval c'est mes jambes et que j'aime
m'exprimer à travers un cheval et sur un
cheval donc c'est une histoire de couple
de ce couple n'est une grande complicité
lecavalier et l'animal ne font plus
qu'un à l'image du centaure créatures
mythologiques
c'est beaucoup de technique beaucoup
d'amour de patience surtout surtout pas
être pressé en fait avec les chevaux
parce qu'ils ont une mémoire énorme et
qu' il faut pas demander des choses trop
vite et surtout mal donc il faut avoir
la patience et l'humilité de recommencer
chaque jour la même chose on travaille
essentiellement avec des chevaux
lusitaniens la marque de l'académie ses
chevaux vous avez pu voir en cas où sexe
des chevaux crème très mélo donc doré
avec des yeux bleus et
qui sont des chevaux c'étaient les
chevaux à l'époque de louis xiv déjà
qu'il utilisait sont des chevaux qui ont
des airs relevés naturelles qui ont un
super mental qui sont très beau show et
donc ils rentrent les aptitudes qu'en
utilisant spectacle chaque spectacle est
suivi d'une visite libre des écuries
l'occasion de découvrir le travail des
écuyers avant la fermeture de l'académie
jusqu'en février 2010 est alors une
place pour ce spectacle ça peut être une
idée cadeau pour le père noël aussi
lorsque les plus grands peuvent aussi en
profiter ya pas que les enfants tout à
fait ma petite camille vous savez les
enfants dans leurs courriers demandent
souvent au père noël de faire un cadeau
à leur papa et leur maman et spectacle
c'est toujours une bonne idée pour faire
avec la doua papa et maman
par exemple exactement et donc après
noël vient le nouvel an après les
cadeaux mélanie poker nous a rejoint en
plateau pour ce dernier rendez-vous
junior de 2016 alors qu'est-ce que vous
avez nous montrer aujourd'hui mélanie
pas les fêtes de fin d'année camus vous
le savez bonjour déjà à tous les deux je
suis très honoré mais c'est le père noël
de d'être avec vous pour cette dernière
chronique de l'année
alors on a beaucoup parlé noël dans les
rendez-vous juniors on a fait le
calendrier de l'avent faire une couronne
décoratives pour sa porte
et si pour cette fin d'année nous
faisait une carte de voeux vous en
envoyer alors oui en général j'essaie
d'en envoyer mais je n'ai pas encore
essayé de les faire à moi même j'avoue
je ne suis pas trop lancé alors répète
nous donner des astuces pour le faire
facilement
on m'a encore lancé un défi d'en
réaliser moi-même alors je les journées
à mener en plateau on les a faits pour
pour la chronique dont vous le voyez ce
sont deux petits sacs mais on peut faire
tout un tas de modèles là aussi des
calendriers de l'après peut-être
pourquoi pas
on peut faire aussi des cartes toutes
simples qui s'ouvre il n'y a pas de
soucis et vous avez rencontré une
passionnée passionnés le mot est faible
alors nicole ressasse se plonge chaque
jour dans des activités manuelles
principalement de la carterie
pour vous donner une idée de la qualité
de ses créations elle a créé plus de 400
cartes pour le marché de noël de
montigny le bretonneux et à l'issue de
ce marché il ne lui en restait qu'une
vingtaine alors le modèle qu'on a choisi
de rails de réaliser on le trouve tout
simplement sur internet c'est une vraie
mine d'or pour le reste il faut trouver
des feuilles cartonnées aux décors de
noël on en trouve autour d'une dizaine
d'euros dans les magasins spécialisés
une petite cordelette paul ans de sacs
et des décorations à votre goût des
petits gants un petit chapeau de père
noël elle cela il faut aussi ajouter une
paire une feuille cartonnée unis de
préférence de 17 cm sur 17 et des petits
scratch pour refermer le sec et c'est
parti alors on commence par dessiner le
gabarit surtout les contours et surtout
n'oubliez pas les piqûres ce sera très
important après on découpe toujours avec
minutie pour pas avoir de surprises et
on commence à plier alors pour plier ce
quand la feuille cartonnée c'est
compliqué on utilise un une règle un
stylo bille qui n'a plus d'encre ça va
faciliter le pillage avant de plier bien
sûr on gomme on le voit à l'image pour
les télés petit trait de crayon peuterey
pas très beau et après on fait deux
petites roues à environ 2 cm du bord de
la piqûre
alors vous allez voir sur les images
nicole elle elle est très bien équipé
mais on peut le faire avec un petit
cutter mais petit conseil à chaque fois
comme à chaque fois qu'on utilise du
matériel coupe en deux jours toujours
sur la direction d'un adulte et le
carton unis alors il sert à créer une
sorte d' enveloppe à l'intérieur mais ça
c'est à partir de plus oui c'est assez
technique vous allez voir moi aussi j'ai
eu un peu de mal surtout que c'était la
première fois que joseph nicole les
faits on va dire presque les doigts dans
le nez alors il faut là aussi faire des
pions comme si on faisait une cocotte en
papier vous savez le petit jeu qu'on
aime tous heures dans la cour de récré
après on trace des carrés à chaque bord
de trois centimètres alors les bords
dans les coins nation fait pas sur le
milieu et après on plie là c'est plus
compliqué on va le voir à l'image mais
il faut que les deux pions du côté
rentre vers le milieu ça fait une espèce
de
d'arbres de triangle et ensuite on colle
tout simplement le carton unis dans le
ce que dans le sac par non et non mais
bien sûr les scratches qui va permettre
de fermer le petit sac
ensuite on va installer la corde à
l'intérieur et puis on pense qu'avec pas
la fin en face à la déco c'est ça et
après donc quand le peu de ça qu'il est
terminé vous n'avez plus qu'à y glisser
un mot une photo ou des bonbons merci
mélanie nous avoir proposé cet atelier
on va se dire un dernier petit mot avec
le père noël après le 25 décembre
vous allez retourner en laponie vous
allez vous reposer un petit peu quand
même
bah écoutez ça tiendrait comme moi on
recommencerait tout de suite il ya
beaucoup de travail et puis c'est un
travail qui est tellement agréable mais
bon les petits lu tard ils sont beaucoup
travaillé les réalisons beaucoup couru
les petits elfes ils ont beaucoup écrit
alors voilà on a décidé avec la mère
noël qu'on leur donnait une journée de
congé alors moi aller se reposer et puis
moi je vais retrouver la mère noël pour
manger bonne chope de noël alors merci
beaucoup père noël d'être venu sur le
plateau du 7-8 loi dit on vous laisse
repartir car voir n va doivent
s'impatienter vous avez encore du
travail pour que tout soit prêt pour le
24 et 25 décembre merci encore on passe
maintenant à notre agenda avec un rendez
vous à noter
un peu d'humour pour clore l'année 2016
samedi 31 décembre fabien olicard et
philippe roesch s'allient pour un
spectacle à la royale factory entre
imitations et drôlerie c'est la fin de
ce set 8 choisir ceux de ce dernier
c'est choisir de 2016 merci de nous
avoir suivis je vous retrouve vendredi 6
janvier pour une nouvelle année d'ici là
je vous souhaite de très bonnes fêtes de
fin d'année
[Musique]